things seem to be heating up between
Jennifer Lopez and Alex Rodriguez and we
don't just mean the temp the lovebirds
spent the weekend together in the
Hamptons soaking up the Summer Sun with
J Lo's nine-year-old twins Max and Emmy
I have to safeguard the quality of my
work the quality of my life with my kids
and it seems safe to say the twins may
have fallen just as hard for the world
of dance star's new beau on Wednesday
JLo took to Instagram with a series of
pic showing her adorable kiddos enjoying
some pool time check out this sweet snap
of Max sitting on the former baseball
pros chest while his sister looks on
with a smile Lopez of course shared
several solo pics of her hunky man and
could anything be cuter than this pic of
the twins sleeping
[Music]
J rods dreamy weekend comes just a few
days after they were spotted strolling
through East Hampton hand-in-hand
each he chatted with Rodriguez before
the couple's latest getaway he couldn't
stop gushing about his leading lady
Jennifer's were the most brilliant
business mind I've ever met she's the
hardest working lady